foreign
correspondence with the facts we
probably think of the facts as in some
sense available to us independently of
what we believe as if you could look and
see the facts just plain in front of you
like a scene
so suppose you think of verification of
a belief in terms of a scene it's all
very well for some beliefs perhaps
um
the Heyday of the correspondence theory
in the early 20th century
was Russell again defended it and
Wittgenstein wittgenstein's first book
was called the tractatus logico
philosophicus in fact it's the only book
that Wittgenstein ever published
Wittgenstein apparently was much
impressed when he wrote that book but I
have seen he'd witnessed in a court in
Paris
uh where the there was something to do
with a traffic accident
and the court was presented evidence in
the form of sort of two dinky toys or
how many dinky toys it took sort of
Meandering around a sort of little you
know dolls house type setup and that
showed the jurors or the judges
um what had happened in the course of
this traffic accident how the accident
happened so as a model
and Wittgenstein thought that seeing
this model was in some sense a paradigm
for of
finding the truth
and the elements of the model
corresponded to elements in the real
world this stinky toy corresponded to
the car that the defendant was driving
this one corresponded to the car that
got crashed into or whatever it was so
you've got this sort of one-to-one
Correspondence between what was shown in
the model and what was shown in the real
world and biggest I thought that's
correspondence came known as the picture
theory of meaning
and it's all very well but it doesn't
seem to work for all facts if you think
about it
it doesn't work very well for negative
facts
for example how could you show a picture
showing that something didn't happen
I've actually got a nice story about
this my family and I have often gone for
walking holidays in Scotland with some
friends who are here indeed and we
started off on the shores of a place
called Loch Dewey under the Five Sisters
of kintail if any of you know the
northwest of Scotland
and there there was a holly tree
in the grounds of the house we were in
and there's a story about this tree
that's when the holly tree grew to the
point at which its trunk
was the size of a car tackle
there was going to be a there's a
prophecy about about chap called The
Graham Seer the breancia the bransia was
a famous Chaplet with prophetic powers
and the exercise is prophetic Powers by
looking through a hole in the stone he
had a stone with a hole in it and when
he looked through this hole he could see
the future and tell you what was going
to happen
which is very impressive I'm not sure
how often his prophecies were verified
but they were certainly quite famous
um and the story is told that we he when
he came to this holly tree which was
very little sapling when he lived in the
16th century
um he looked through his
the hole in the stone and he gave the
prophecy and the prophecy was when this
holly tree is trunk is big enough to
form the axle of a cart
a great battle will not be fought on
this spot
[Laughter]
you have to ask yourself what did he see
um and
um and there's no answer I mean uh he
couldn't possibly have seen something
which deserved uh predicting as a great
battle had not been fought on be fought
on this spot but what did happen was
about 70 years later when the holly tree
had indeed grown quite a lot
um two armies I think it was General
Monk and Montrose was it in the uh the
covenanting wars in Scotland in the
early 17th century
um one went down locked doick and the
other Army went up lot long which is
parallel to it and they missed
so so so in fact it was true that a
great battle was not fought on this spot
um
but you can't just see a scene in which
it's correct to describe it as a great
battle was not we well you couldn't say
there's no great battle being fought
here tonight but
um uh but it wouldn't it wouldn't have
Justified the Graham's Seer the brain
seer in making that prediction
anyhow the point is that when you've got
complex beliefs of belief in this case
of a negative fact
it's not like having the scene it's not
like
um it's not something that's simply be
shown you again it's got it's got to be
an interpretation of the scene and it's
through the
um
through the arrival of different
interpretations of scenes that we form
our beliefs and uh you know decide
what's the case
so correspondence only gets you so far
if if anywhere
coherence on the other hand doesn't
quite cut it because you can have
coherent stories that are false
so where do you go next
well there was a
a movement in philosophy
parallel to the arrivals some of you may
have heard of the arrival of analytical
philosophy which was largely due to
Russell and more at the beginning of the
20th century
well there's a parallel movement going
on in America called pragmatism
and that's what I want to talk to you
about the
um
the principal pragmatist was Charles
Sanders purse C.S purse a very very fine
philosopher who's actually not a
professional philosopher who's a
professional
professionally his life was with the
United States Geological Survey who is a
scientist and
um but nevertheless he wrote extensively
about philosophy he's part of the a
group of people surrounded you know
basically surrounding William James in
Harvard
and purse really was the moving Spirit
along with some other people there's
always some people other people in a
philosophical movement
he was the leading light of pragmatism
and he was probably the best pragmatist
William James
had a lot of pizzazz about him and wrote
about pragmatism
um but purse was there before him
anyhow purse began I think the the
emphasis on practice as the litmus test
of
truth so truths were going to be the
things which were useful
the simplest
form this Theory could take would be the
views the truth is utility and William
James himself actually used that kind of
formula
um
so James for example then came across I
mean he was criticized
vehemently criticized by Russell and
more
um they said that James basically
thought that wishful thinking gave you
the truth
so if you found a belief very convenient
if you liked it if you
hoped that it was true that was
eventually a matter of it being true
because it was useful to you to believe
it
um but that that's not the form that
utility has to take if it's going to be
a litmus test for truth
um it might be useful to you and
pleasant to believe that you're the most
popular child in the class
um but if 20 people each believe that
then 19 of them are wrong
um so even if it's useful for each of
them to believe it
so believing of yourself that you're a
popular
might be useful it's good for your frame
of mind
but it's not true
so there's again you know the the as a
definition it just seems to fall down
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas